sa che voglia di giocare oggi a poche
volte io nella mia vita a rimpiango di
fare lo youtuber perché in genere è un
lavoro che mi piace nel senso gioco
videogiochi e la mia passione quindi mi
piace fare come faccio grandi in
rarissimi casi e questo è uno di quelli
getting over it by bennet fondi continua
continua ma mi state prendendo per il
culo per arrivare dove ero arrivato
nello scorso episodio ci ho messo
qualcosa come un ora
quindi mi devo rifare tutto meraviglioso
questo giorno gesù
eravamo arrivati qui ci aveva messo una
vita per arrivare qui ci abbiamo rimesso
una vita di nuovo se stai già visto che
parli sempre bene con quale fisica mi
son fermato non so solo io già vacca
laida come faccio ad aggrapparmi a quei
cosi maledetti porca eva trono ma com'è
che mi spiega l'ultima volta come avevo
porca vacca non è nono non ammazzo ti
ama fra tende ammazzo te lo giuro
ok possiamo salire qua sopra è così
difficile deve essere salire qua sopra
mi si può chiedere di registrare queste
cagate la domenica a gesù buono poi
appoggia poggia riuscire a poggiare il
culetto
ok no
ve lo giuro ragazzino è stato non è
possibile nella vita arrivo ad un certo
io ve lo giuro questo gioco mi fa salire
l'abominio che in me l'abominio corre
presso nell'ultima vita dio cioè io
veramente non ci voglio credere non ci
posso credere non sto scherzando cioè io
questa roba qua e non la posso giocare
una persona normale non può giocare a
questi a questo schifo sollecitare i var
e con un suo come possiamo andare avanti
dal punto di partenza che era questo del
mio video sono solo tornato indietro per
ora per l'amore di gesù a natale non
giocata questa roba per l'amor di dio vi
creato un posto all'inferno ragazzi come
una vip lounge all'inferno
puoi stare fermo qui senza fare troppo
casino
no perché nel cervello cia il tua madre
morta ok va bene per colpa per l'amore
di gesù possiamo passare questa parte vi
prego possiamo passarla nel senso
possiamo andare avanti poi posso anche
bloccarmi dopo non i partiti
madonna ti ammazzo ti disintegro la
stirpe cioè non hai capito
no no no no
gesù
oh mio dio piano piano piano per
cortesia ok grazie gesù chiudo io devo
cambiare felpa caldo calcina veramente
anche perché poi quando mi
spazientiscono nizio dare come un cane
allora siamo arrivati ad un punto in più
alla madonna
stavo facendo le cose non tornare
indietro per cortesia ed è capace che da
qua attorno all'inizio pure la nostra è
capace questo gioco non mi stupirei
neanche burqa ma che ci sta riuscendo
per assurdo mi sembra anche un
pochettino più semplice basta a tirarsi
su forte aspetta cosa devo fare devo a
minchia
e vabbè quanto difficile ma siete scemi
ma veramente aiutare piano spingiti un
po ok o inc
è incredibile perché probabilmente era
una cosa difficile da fare sono riuscito
a farla bene stai zitto scritto ancora
che parla già incredibile se io cado qua
ragazzi parte che mi sa che devo andare
dall'altra parte gesù che lo devo andare
deve andare qua
la cosa che mi rincuora di più non è
neanche che sta andando avanti ma chiede
se cadono un cadeau all'inizio di maggio
almeno quella parte non la rivedo più
come broadway come broadway ma tua
sorella broadway ma sul serio non si può
andare di qua a minchia dover aggiungere
la scala lì ma sei scemo che casino
l'ho preso l'ho presa no se non
riuscendo ma che musica brutta o gesù
porca vacca per un millimetro ogni volta
[Musica]
a gesù stavo scherzando
eh no vai se prima non riuscì a tre
volte di fila ci sono riuscito adesso ce
la fai a tirarti su mai nella vita forse
sì forse sì
cosa devo fare con acquisti aggrapparmi
alla video che ma stai scherzando come
faccio non hai capito aiuto può fare non
è vero che è nato gesù
no no no no aiuto
ti giuro io veramente sento male alle
braccia io c'è veramente africa il mouse
avanti e indietro sommare alle braccia
io e il gioco più straziante che abbia
mai fatto in tutta la mia vita ragazzi
ve lo giuro non farò ma se mai dovessi
approcciare un gioco del genere ancora
stai zitto fa mi stai zitto te lo chiedo
per cortesia te lo chiedo veramente per
favore stai zitto non bisogna né nel
momento di parlare porca vacca sti
divani ecco questo succede quando non
sai montare le cose all'ikea casino
incredibile stava andando esattamente in
tutto questo ma voi avete capito più o
meno sto gioco dove che ci deve portare
avanti non so se avete capito ma mi sta
chiedendo di andare espressamente sul
tavolino e di saltare sulla roccia di in
alto seccato
potrebbe darsi che ritorna addirittura
all'inizio del gioco e cioè io non ho
parole rai a madonna senza neanche
preparazione un fenomeno un fenomeno tua
madre morta dove sono finito fisc ciao
bambino stupido ma io mi sa che prima
quando sono salito sulla scala mi son
saltato metà livello perché per questa
parte non ci sono mai stato prima
mi sa che prima mi ero saltato un sacco
di parti sono andata al punto in cui
l'esasperazione talmente tanta che tanto
più sotto non posso andare quindi non mi
mandate messaggi che sono incazzati
ormai sono praticamente allo stremo
delle mie forze senza paura senza paura
senza paura si fanno le cose
esatto di una vacca incastrata nel duomo
senza paura una sega prima l'avevo fatto
non sapevo dove sarei caduto marras
aperta
a quanti problemi
quanti problemi sto gioco del diavolo
quanti maledizione raga io basta non
basta togli l'audio non ci posso fare
togli l'audio dalmazzo zitto zitto stai
zitto madonna stai zitto mamma mia che
nervoso quest'uomo dovuto togliere
l'audio ci rendete conto donna li lo
spacco qualcosa madonna datemi qualcosa
per sfogarmi che lo giuro mazzo vi
spacco qualcosa oggi di un giorno ma
comprendo qualcosa lo lancio in giro
ammazzo mi appendo mito lo slancio non
riesco a prenderlo torno giù per dal
meno slancio midolo slancio non riesco a
prenderlo ritorno giovino lo slancio e
così via e l'inferno e questo questo il
girone dell'inferno quadro e fissa la
gente che bestemmia vogliono farmela
pesa tanto questa cosa andiamo avanti
non lo so continuiamo così in eterno va
bene agganciamo c ritiro su non riesco a
prenderlo torniamo viti l'aggancio mi
tiro su non lo prendo non posso fare
questa vita io non è possibile come qui
perché a volte sì a volte nostro e con
che criterio di fisica a volte ci arriva
e a volte non ci arriva porca vacca o
perché adesso sì perché adesso comunque
c'era arrivato e le altre volte no che
provini avevi l'altra volte spiega mi
succede sbagliato in quello che faccio
in quel video spero che vi sia piaciuto
e mi piace perché mario rispetto a
questo gioco
lo so che non fa ridere però mi ha
regalato questa maglia l'ho messa da
ragazzi
[Musica]